hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome back to my channel you know
if you've been liking the uh videos I've
been putting out be sure to subscribe to
the channel
um you know like And subscribe to it and
you know if you guys ever have any
comments you want to make about order
flow or trading in general
um you know just be sure to put them in
the in the comments section below I do
go through them I'm a bit more
proactively than I have in the past and
you know I was looking at some of the
comments uh that I got recently and you
know there's a couple of comments that I
just wanted to comment on
um you know that really sort of struck
me as you know sort of the reason why
um you know people struggle with trading
in general not just with order flow
um you know on one of the videos I made
recently uh someone commented
this will take at least a decade to
learn nearly impossible no I I really
disagree with that you know it's order
flow is not that complicated I don't
understand why people think it's going
to be you know take forever to learn you
know a footprint chart is very basic
it's just basic information of what's
trading on the bid and the offer you
know if you've ever worked in a Trading
Company you know whether it's a bank or
a trading uh commodity trading firm or
you know even in even in a prop firm I
don't give you a decade to sit down and
learn you know there's that whole
misconception of oh it takes ten
thousand hours to master something you
know ten thousand hours is you know if
you're working a full-time job you know
40 hours a week 50 weeks a year that's 2
000 hours right that you know so 10 000
hours is five years you know it's you
know people use it in the sports
um realm but you know when it comes to
the trading realm you know if you know
you go work for a bank or you know a
trading firm and you know they only give
you a few months three months if that to
become profitable they're not going to
give you a decade to learn so you know
trying to analyze order flow
is you know maybe not using you know all
the pieces in your brain because you
know we go through order flow on a daily
basis we just don't realize it
um you know you have to in a sense
internalize it right did it take you 10
years to learn how to drive a car no it
took you a few weeks right to understand
sort of the basic mechanics of driving
you know turning on the car
pulling out into traffic you know
driving on the expressway and not
getting killed right you're still alive
right you can drive a car it didn't take
you 10 years to master how to drive a
car you know it took experience it took
time you need to have some screen time
and at the end of the day what order
flow is it's not a trading strategy
right it's not an indicator it's just
data from the market right it's telling
you what traded
at what price the volume was it traded
on the bid was it volume traded on the
offer
um did it leave an imbalance
um was it heavy volume was it light
volume and it's up to you to learn to
decipher it and honestly it doesn't take
10 years uh to learn doesn't take five
years right
um you know you could learn it a lot
quicker depending on you know everyone
learns at a different level I guess but
order flow at the end of the day it's
just data it's data generated from the
market right I mean guys that traded on
the floor right Floor Traders
they didn't spend 10 years trying to
master the order flow you know they had
to pick it up pretty quick otherwise
they would go broke they couldn't afford
to pay for their seats Etc
and you know back in those days you know
it was still not cheap to become a
member but one of the reasons why
exchange memberships were so high is you
could see the order flow you could see
when you know the big brokerage firm or
the big bank was buying and selling
um you know and seeing you know how much
was on the bid how much was on the offer
things like that and you know when
you're trading on a screen things are
different but you can see the actual now
you can actually see the volume whereas
before you know if you were a big Trader
and you know and you're trading off the
floor you'd have to call the floor and
talk to the guys on the floor the floor
um you know the phone Clerk or sometimes
the broker would come out of the pit and
talk to you guys out talk to you on the
phone saying oh yeah so-and-so did this
so and so did that but now we live in
this information age this computer age
where it's all right there on the screen
every trade that goes through on the
exchange level prints on the screen and
actually makes it in my opinion a hell
of a lot easier to see what's going on
so
again for example I did a lot of videos
on this last week right just talking
about thin prints in the bar okay this
is ultra bonds
if I were to just turn on the thin
prints in the bar it's a very simple
concept right it's not
brain surgery right you don't have to
sit here and worry about Gamma and Vega
and all these option Greeks you just got
to look at the volume
in the order flow right on the footprint
chart so I'm just going to look at
this is a foreign range
ultrabond chart I'm just going to look
for those areas inside the bar where
there was a lack of volume traded okay
simple simple simple simple okay down
here
there was a zero in here okay again it's
colored red because that's bearish okay
well Market sold off a couple ticks then
made a new low now it's coming back up
here you've got a zero print on the way
back up and now you get the bigger move
another zero print in here and then you
start adding in other parts of order
flow analysis okay well what do I what
how about you know when there's some
form of imbalance in the market okay
like a stacked imbalance meaning three
or more imbalances stacked neatly on top
of each other okay let's take a look
let's just simply turn on the indicator
to look for stacked buying and stacked
selling imbalances okay so you just
scroll down in here
um stacked and balancing and set that to
three minimum cluster size three
and turn it on
okay well I know here there's a stacked
buying imbalance okay so now that I got
the thin volume I got no volume rather
it's a zero print inside the bar which
is quite strong I also got a stacked
Vine and balance in there okay I know
that the low was made low of the day was
just made you know about 10 minutes
earlier now I got strong aggressive
buying coming in right I can take that
information because all this is all that
you're looking here is just information
of what traded in the market and how it
traded
to pull the trigger okay now that sort
of leads me to the next comment on here
um that I got uh it's frustrating to
watch his videos I'm giving up now okay
fine give up
um and never tell a strategy it's it's I
I feel like I've been given strategies
every day it's up to you I give you sort
of ways to look at the market you
develop your strategy part of trading is
you know it's a personal Journey finding
what works for you what makes sense to
you I'm not trying to go out there and
say this is what you have to do because
Mike says it has to be this I have to
trade it this way right all I do is go
through past action telling it went up
it went down yeah I tell you why it went
up why it went down so that when you see
it again you know what to do right
that's the whole point of Education to
educate people but I guess you know some
people aren't interested in in learning
right they just just tell me where to
buy just tell me where to sell in that
case you shouldn't be watching trading
videos just find a hedge fund or
investment fund or you know a money
market fund rather just throw your money
in there and and leave it be
um you know what's the point that the
whole point is so you can learn and wrap
your head around what's happening in the
market can you show your trades at least
record based on your strategy there's so
many different strategies honestly I'm
just teaching you what to look for and
I've done live trading workshops
um you know I do those several times
over the year and you know I take
Traders through exactly what I'm looking
for because you know every time I could
look at a chart today right for example
I could look at this chart
and if I say okay I'm going to teach you
what to look for on this day is going to
be this this and this and it doesn't
develop then the whole day is wasted
right so when I do like my live training
workshops
I'm going through the order flow with
you as it's developing what's developing
and how to trade it so you know there's
many different ways to look at this this
data right more than just one way I mean
you can that's what I tell beginning
Traders is just sort of focus on the one
part of order flow that resonates with
you and go from there okay
and again you know even when I've shared
my trading records in the past
um you know and everyone that's been in
the live trading sessions they've seen
it as well
excuse me people oh you know he just got
lucky or you know he had a good couple
of days or a good week Etc you know they
still don't want to believe you know
it's like those you know the the Navy
rescue team right the boat capsizes
there's five guys in the water
right and the guy that's coming down
from the helicopter has to make the
decision well who do I save well you
saved the one that's swimming towards
you that wants to be saved the one
that's just sort of flapping his hands
in the water is probably going to be the
last one that's going to get saved or
he'll just drown but at least uh you
know other people get it right
um pvof says how would you ever know
trade records we're real or not anyway
so I can easily take my real statement
and edit it and turn all the losers into
winners right everything is fake now
just look at all those FX influencers
who show
fake profit and loss statements you know
exactly right it's not about showing
the profit and loss statements that oh
that you're going to make me a Believer
right it's like you know I even replied
to this comment saying you know he gets
it right DB gets it right he understands
these are instructional videos so you
could test and build your own ideas
exactly yes exactly right in trading
nothing works 100 and nothing works at
all if you know I have faith and
confidence to take a trade perfect
perfect explanation right this
confidence is built
when you yourself have tested your ideas
and know exactly what conditions under
which they work or not no one can teach
you how to trade like them you know and
that that's that's important to know
because you know I do get some Traders
you'll just tell me you know I want to
learn how you trade exactly well no
you're not going to be an exact clone of
how I trade and I wouldn't want people
to be that way right you got to be a
free thinker you got to think for
yourself right I always say the best
computer is the one between your
shoulders right the one inside your your
skull there this is a function of your
own personality and your own hard work
and efforts exactly yes
preach brother or preach you you get it
you understand but still you know some
people they just don't get it right
um you know for what it's worth I could
sit here and I can say all you have to
do
is just focus on when a zero prints in
the bar internally on a bar in a thick
Market I think market mean a market that
trades a lot of volume and build your
trading strategy around there you know
for example right if we just go back to
you know this is the e-minis
um
e-mini chart now when I first released
the software back in 2015
okay and and I released it because again
other Traders were asking me for it and
there was one traitor he just he even
said you know I've been this is how he
trades right he uses my exhaustion
prints right there was there was at that
time there was like five four or five
tools one of them was the exhaustion
Prince
okay
um default is set to nine
and let me just get the the chart up
here right it was all even though I had
ratios on there imbalance reversals
um zero prints
these exhaustion prints
after he got my software he's like you
know the reason why I bought your
software
is very upfront about is because you
know I have my own ways of determining
support and resistance right but I want
to be highlighted to those areas where
there's potential exhaustion so if this
is an area where his you know res chart
is showing resistance and he's coming up
here and he's seen exhaustion prints
which is a sign of you know lack of
interest in buying that's his go signal
that yeah that this resistance
it's probably going to hold because we
don't have that strong buying taking
place up here right it's not about
learning how exactly how I trade and
trying to become a Trader like me it's
about taking what I've teach and what I
advocate
um you know as a way as approaches to
the market
and using it in your own trading right
and quite honestly if
the things that I talk about in these
videos you know over the years and you
know even Tools in my software if they
weren't useful all these other software
companies wouldn't be copying them
Sierra charts is you know you go through
the Forum people are asking can you add
this can you add that a lot of it is
what's already built into my software
right the problem is when people buy the
other software they don't understand how
to use it right you can just open up
ninjatrader for example or any other
charting platform
and you're going to see all these tools
in there
right Buy cell pressure buy one camera
pivots Candlestick patterns CCI uh you
know choppiness index correlation
obviously darba Dima disparity index
do you use any of those no because you
don't know how to use them it's not
about just taking a tool from somebody
else and say oh yeah I know how that's
calculated I put up my chart but you
know
what's the practical application of it
right that that's why I do these videos
is to teach people what to look for
right because if you have a tool of mine
you know I want to make sure you
understand how to use it and how to
benefit from it and again you know order
flow doesn't take 10 years
it doesn't take five years doesn't take
three years
all you have to do is you got to find
the pieces of order flow that makes
sense to you right when I started
trading an order flow chart
now granted I had been in the markets
for a while and I understood order flow
you know how how it really what it was
because I literally started trading
um the electronic sessions you know on
the trading desk at Dean Witter when
Globex first started trade um started
back in the the 90s early 90s right you
had CME had Globex Board of Trade had
um
started out as Aurora and basically just
called project a
um nymex Comics had access okay and you
know sitting there staring at those
screams staring at the the the book
basically
um you know I learned a lot of what to
look for and how the markets uh react so
you know I feel I have an edge and you
know Traders nowadays when they come
into the markets they don't have that
advantage of
um you know
getting a job at a trading firm anything
like that nowadays it's very difficult
to get a job at a training firm you know
they want to have a certain background
certain education but you know I was
fortunate to get in when I was able to
get in and I was able to learn order
flow right and the importance of order
flow so for example right I was just
talking about the the thin prints in the
bar right the zeros taking place in the
bar so let's just take a look here at
e-minis if there was any in here right
these are just tools right these are not
trading strategies what you do is you
take a tool then you build out a
strategy from it and if you're looking
for me to hold your hand and build out a
strategy for you personally no you know
you have to find out what your risk
tolerance is you know how much heat are
you willing to take when you're in a
trade some people can take a lot of heat
on a trade
other people can't take much okay so
here right I see
uses zero okay Market sold off a little
bit coming back up there's a zero right
here we trade it right back to that
point here's a zero right here went up
came right back to that point
okay just as here right there's a zero
here we sold off came right back up to
that point came off a little bit
and it came back up so again you know
order flow is not meant to be a strategy
in and of itself it's just data it's the
market basically right and it's up to
you to to analyze it the way a doctor
would analyze an x-ray right I could
look at it the same x-ray as my doctor
and I wouldn't know what's wrong with me
but he'll look at the X-ray oh this this
this and that is wrong with you you got
Colvin you're going to die or something
but um yeah I could look at it and say
ah I don't know what that means
um you know and same thing with order
flow you have to know what to look for
and that's the whole point of these
videos is to educate you so you know if
you're finding you're getting value out
from my videos you know be sure to
comment on that you know I I do
appreciate the comments you know from
from traders that say you know they're
getting stuff from my videos that they
can develop and you know go with in
their own
trading so thanks everyone it's a bit of
a rant today but you know I just want to
get that off my chest because you know
it does I see it bothers me but it just
has me shaking my head I mean you know
people talk about the failure rate in
trading but it's like people give up
before they even get started right so
hopefully uh you guys are not like that
and you know you're willing to uh take
the time to understand what's happening
in the markets all right everyone have a
great day